Ngày Một Tháng Bệnh, ngàn Ý tế thành phố Chí Minh sẽ có thay đổi lớn với 2 chi cục và 1,5 mươi đơn vị trực thuộc.
Trong đó, ông 22.8, 2.8 bệnh viện truyền khoa, môi môi trung tâm không dưới mệnh,
mấy lâm trung tâm bảo trở sở hội và 3.8 chung tâm ít tế khu vực.
Đối với Bộ Một Mê Ba chạm Ý tế phường, xá hiện hiểu vẫn thực hiện giám vụ,
chức năng như hiện nay để không sảo trộn hoạt động trong xóc xuất khỏe bàn đầu trong rửa dân.
Trong thời gian sảo mấy ngày sau ngày 1,5 mưu tháng bệnh, ngàn Ý khu chăm 20,
xời Ý tế sẽ thực hiện chuyển đổi thành 1,5 mưu tâm trạm ít tế phường, xá tưởng với số phường,
xá mới và tế lập 2 trong chi mê xáu điểm ít tế.
Trung tâm ít tế khu vực đam chắc ít tế bộ xung của những lực cho các trạm ít tế và điểm ít tế.
Nếu hệ thống cấp kiểu 1,5 mưu thân và 1 mưu mê làm trạm cấp kiểu vệ tình sẽ được mở giọng hạo lối vệ tình để báo phủ tàn bộ để bản mối.
ngoài ra, tương emu 1 tháng bệnh, tại thành phố Chỉ Minh có 1 trong mối trung tâm bảo trở xá hội.
1 mưu lâm cơ sở công lập và chỉ 1 mưu lâm cơ sở ngoài công lập.